[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
unter Militärs gibt es ja den Spruch
Amateure sprechen von Strategie Profis
von Logistik eine alte kriegsweisheit
sozusagen die sich immer wieder
bewahrheitet was nutzen einem die
stärksten Panzer wenn man sie nicht
schnell repariert bekommt was ich im
Zweifelsfall nicht mal eben so am
Straßenrand erledigen lässt
daher ist es für die Ukraine schon
wichtig dass in Rammstein heute
beschlossen wurde ein entsprechendes
instandhaltungszentrum in Polen
einzurichten auch sonst zeigte sich der
ukrainische Verteidigungsminister sehr
zufrieden mit dem Verlauf des Treffens
ich habe danach mit ihm gesprochen
zunächst aber der Bericht von Florian
neuhahn er beginnt mit dem Auftritt des
us-verteidigungsministers den man
anmerkte dass ihm die Pentagon liegt
doch recht peinlich sind
es dauert nicht lange da kommt Leute aus
den heute auf unglaubliche Solidarität
zu sprechen aber der
US-Verteidigungsminister meint nicht wie
sonst die der westlichen Staaten mit der
Ukraine sondern bei einer zerknirscht
die Solidarität der Verbündeten mit
seinem Land
ich bin beeindruckt wie solidarisch
unsere Partner sind und wie sehr sie
jeden Versuch uns zu spalten
zurückweisen nichts wird unsere Einheit
zerstören
auch nicht die Pentagon leaks die
geheimen Dokumente zum ukraine-krieg die
ausgerechnet aus Austins Ministerium an
die Öffentlichkeit kamen und die auch
enthüllen wie hoch die Verlustrate der
Ukraine ist wie groß ihr Bedarf an
nachschüttet seitdem die Ukraine im
November vergangenen Jahres Carson
zurückeroberte verlieren Russen und
Ukrainer viel und gewinnen wenig
die Lage deutet im Moment auf ein Paten
aber das wird auch davon abhängen ob und
wann die Ukraine ihre geplante früher
als Offensive tatsächlich verwirklicht
die geplante Offensive sie schwebt auch
über diesen Treffen der Unterstützer
starten in Ramstein wo ist heute weniger
um neue Waffen geht viel mehr darum dass
die bereits gelieferten wieder
funktionieren
jedes Material was sie in diesen Krieg
lieferner Panzer oder Kampf
unterstützungspanzer und andere
Gerätschaften wie Haubitzen oder eben
patriot-systeme haben Verschleiß gerade
dann wenn Sie im Gefecht im Dauereinsatz
sind wenn möglich sollen solche Panzer
künftig wieder repariert werden in einem
Zentrum nahe der ukrainischen Grenze
schon Ende Mai könnte es losgehen darauf
einigen sich heute die Minister aus
Deutschland der Ukraine und Polen
die Absichtserklärung zur Errichtung
eines
instandsetzungszentrums schon ein
historischer Moment das wirkt als müsse
der Westen sich Mut zu sprechen
das zeigt unsere Entschlossenheit dass
wir durchhalten wollen Putin kann nicht
auf Zeit spielen wir werden durchhalten
die Ukraine haben den Mut und die
Fähigkeiten für das was jetzt kommt und
wir stehen Ihnen zur Seite so lange wie
nötig
und die liegt aus seinem Haus der
Nato-Generalsekretär geradeaus zurück
beschwichtigt
der Informationen manipuliert wurden
diese likes haben kein bisschen
verändert wie wir mit der Ukraine
zusammenarbeiten
unklar wie viel Hoffnung in dieser
Aussage steckt so wie in dem Treffen
heute Hoffnung auf die Offensive
und der Verteidigungsminister der
Ukraine ist uns aus Ramstein
zugeschaltet olexesel resnikov guten
Abend Herr reznikov
ja ich grüße Sie ebenfalls wie zufrieden
sind Sie mit dem Verlauf des Treffens
heute wurde ihnen das zugesagt was sie
noch brauchen für die angekündigte
Offensive
Sitzung im Randstein
war die Hälfte und wir hatten ja
eigentlich ein jahresstag es war genau
am
April und genau in Deutschland als wir
uns zum ersten Mal getroffen haben in
diesem Club Rammstein Chlor wie ich das
nenne ich bin sehr zufrieden mit der
heutigen Saison ich hatte die
Möglichkeit unser Prioritäten zu
präsentieren
mich hat begleitet der Stellvertreter
der Leiter
des
aufklärungsstabs und zwei Generäle und
wir hatten die Möglichkeit unseren
Kollegen zu berichten was zur Zeit in
der Ukraine passiert auf dem
Schlachtfeld und welche Hilfe wir von
unseren Partnern erwarten
ein Problem der Ukraine ist ja dass sie
immer wieder nach Langstreckenwaffen
also Waffen mit längerer Reichweite
Marschflugkörper und fragt weil sie eben
bisher doch sehr beschränkt ist in dem
wo Sie welche russischen Stellungen sie
erreichen kann also die Russen schießen
gewissermaßen aus sicherer Entfernung
vom eigenen Territorium und der Westen
möchte nicht dass die Ukrainer
eskalieren und die Russen auf ihrem
eigenen Boden angreifen ist das etwas
worüber sie heute gesprochen haben und
wo sie noch mal gedrängt haben auch
solche Waffensysteme zu bekommen
immer wieder im Gespräch mit unseren
Partnern das auf dem ukrainischen Gebiet
unter anderem auch darunter auch die
beseitigen besetzten Gebiete zur zeit
genug Ziel existieren damit wir das
russische militärprinzial vernichten
können
deshalb brauchen wir zurzeit keine neuen
Waffen mit einer reicht weiter über 80
km wie Heimat z.B und ich bin aber
optimistisch was die Zukunft betrifft
dass wir auch weitere Reichweite von
unseren Partnern erreichen Besuch 150 km
aber wenn ich dann noch mal nachhaken
habe die Russen sitzen den Belarus und
lassen von dort kam Flieger aufsteigen
sie wir schießen sie mit Schiffen vom
Schwarzen Meer sie beschäftigt
beschießen sie aus Belgrad also aus dem
Grenzgebiet ist das kein Problem für die
ukrainische Armee und für ihre
Verteidigung
ist ja die Ukraine und das ist eine
vorübergehend besetztes Gebiet wir haben
ja Waffen die auch diese Gebiete
durchaus erreichen können wir brauchen
zurzeit keine westlichen Waffen um
russischer Objekt auf dem russischen
Gebiet anzugreifen bzw zu vernichten wir
haben durch auch außer ukrainischer
Waffen aus der ukrainischen Produktion
und ein ganz frisches Beispiel dafür am
April vor einem Jahr haben wir ne das
Flaggschiff der Ukraine der russischen
Flotte vernichtet
versenkt am 14 echt april vor einem Jahr
ist dieser Schiff gesunken und ich denke
wir brauchen eine gute Mischung
russischer
bzw ukrainischer und westlicher Waffen
unserer Waffen werden wir für die Ziele
benutzen die wir für notwendig halten
und die westlichen Waffen nur zur
Befreiung der besetzten Gebiete am
besten macht man sich unter anderem
Sorgen ob die Munition vor allem auch
Artilleriegeschosse ausreichen werden im
Moment verbraucht die ukrainische Armee
mehr als der als die Europäer zum
Beispiel produzieren wird dieses Problem
gelöst werden haben Sie darüber heute
auch gesprochen
das ist eines der wichtigsten Themen in
der jetzigen Rammstein
der heutige Krieg und der Moderne Krieg
und der größte Krieg in der letzten 80
Jahren in dieser Welt ist natürlich ein
Krieg der Ressourcen Gott sei Dank zum
Glück haben wir
ein guter Ressourcen seitens der Partner
und hinten Rammstein sind viel mehr als
54 Länder vertreten bei uns sie helfen
uns alle und selbstverständlich reicht
diese Lieferung dieser Menge nie aus und
wird auch nicht ausreichen wir haben
natürlich gehört heute auch über die
weiteren Lieferungen der Munition an die
Ukraine
gesprochen und wir haben auch neue
Bestellungen angestoßen um und neue
Waffen bzw neue
Raketen
Luftabwehrraketen
zu produzieren dabei ging es auch um
155er Geschosse für Haubitzen für
Kanonen bzw 120er Kaliber für die Panzer
ich danke für das Gespräch
und ich ich danke Ihnen und ich danke
dem ganzen deutschen Volk Deutschland
der deutschen Regierung dem Deutschen
Bundestag für diesen bereits neuen
Standpunkt und sie machen die Sache im
Interesse der ganzen zivilisierten Welt
und sie haben diese Führungsrolle
unnommen unter anderem auch in der
panzerkollektion die Deutschen als hier
verteidigen den ukrainischen Himmel sehr
erfolgreich und wir werden uns freuen
über noch mehr Unterstützung vielen Dank
beteiligungsminister danke schön
das Interview haben wir heute Nachmittag
gleich im Anschluss an das
ramstein-treffen Aufgezeichnet ich habe
mich mit Verteidigungsminister resnikov
dann noch etwas länger über die
Perspektiven der Ukraine für einen
NATO-Beitritt unterhalten das Gespräch
in ganzer Länge können Sie online sehen
auf ZDF heute
die Ukraine hat nicht nur ein Problem
mit dem Munitionsnachschub sie braucht
auch mehr Soldaten auch in der Hinsicht
ist diese Krieg asymmetrisch nicht nur
dass die Russen auf ihrem Territorium
weitgehend unbehelligt bleiben Putin
kann auch aus einer weit größeren
Bevölkerung zwangsrekrutieren und
Menschen als Kanonenfutter verheizen
ohne dass ihnen das in Moskau politisch
in Gefahr bringt die Ukraine kann mit
ihren Söhnen und Töchtern so nicht
umgehen aber auch sie schafft es
offenbar nicht länger nur auf diejenigen
zu setzen die sich freiwillig melden
daran berichtet aus Soda
die Ukraine braucht Soldaten in nur
deshalb wird für die Armee auf der
Straße mobilisiert Einsatz Besprechung
Alexander leitet die Gruppe im Fokus
sind erfahrene gut ausgebildete Männer
der Wirtschaftsjurist wurde letztes Jahr
selbst einberufen
adäquate motivierte Menschen keine
antisozialen Personen oft entstammen sie
der Mittelschicht sie müssen gesund sein
und sollen ausgebildet sein oder eine
höhere Bildung haben
die Anforderungen an Rekruten steigen
auch aufgrund von moderner westlicher
Militärtechnik es gibt nur wenige Gründe
die Wehrpflichtige Männer von der
Einberufung befreien
wenn man Vater von drei Kindern ist wenn
man eine behinderte Person versorgen
muss dann wird man nicht eingezogen wenn
man aus beruflichen Gründen Aufschub
braucht dann kann man zurückgestellt
werden
dafür muss man Dokumente vorlegen die
das belegen in diesen Fällen muss man
nicht dienen
dieser Mann hingegen passt ins Raster
der Mobilisierung Aufnahme der
Personalien
selbstständig muss ich jetzt innerhalb
der nächsten 7 Tage im Rekrutierungsbüro
melden erst dort wird über seine
Einberufung entschieden
mit Geld zu unterstützen ist eine Sache
aber ich bin nicht sicher ob ich einen
anderen Menschen töten kann
selig bin ich nicht darauf vorbereitet
aber wir werden sehen
ein Recht auf Kriegsdienstverweigerung
gibt es nicht mit der Unterschrift rückt
die Front für ihn näher
ich denke an meine Familie ich bin
Alleinverdiener ich weiß nicht wie sie
ohne mich auskommen
sehr hier hat nur zwei Kinder die
ukrainische mehr leidet Verluste
Frontsoldaten benötigten Kampfpausen nur
freiwillige einzuberufen reicht nicht
mehr aus auch wegen der möglichen
Großoffensive
und jetzt die Nachrichten Heinz der ist
erstmal um die waren Streiks heute ja
10.000 der Pendler und Bahnreisende muss
man heute umdisponieren für mehrere
Stunden standen am Vormittag fast alle
Züge still Warnstreiks in der laufenden
Tarifrunde die meisten Frage ist der
hatten sich allerdings gut eingestellt
auf den Warnstreik der schon einige Tage
angekündigt war die Gewerkschaft EVG
hatte aufgerufen und will Druck machen
vor den am Dienstag in Fulda anstehenden
Gesprächen mit der Deutschen Bahn
Bundesfamilienministerin Paus fordert
mit Blick auf die Folgen der
corona-pandemie die Sorgen und Nöte von
Kindern und Jugendlichen ernst zu nehmen
in einer Bundestagsdebatte zu dem Thema
sagte Pauls die Folgen von
Schulschließungen und
kontaktbeschränkungen wirkten nach am
härtesten betroffen sein Kinder aus
sozial benachteiligten Familien auch
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
verwies auf die besondere Belastung für
die Kinder und das viele heute noch
unter psychischen Störungen litten
und es Innenministerin Väter hatte eine
internationale Kommission zur
Aufarbeitung des Olympia Attentats von
1972 in München eingesetzt
dass für die Hinterbliebenen quälende
Fragen viel zu lange offen geblieben
sein
palästinensische Terroristen hatten
damals Mitglieder der israelischen
Mannschaft als Geiseln genommen bei der
Geiselnahme und der gescheiterten
Befreiungsaktion wurden 11 Israelis und
ein Polizist getötet
der britische Premierminister regissonak
verliert ein weiteres wichtiges
Regierungsmitglied seinen Stellvertreter
und Justizminister Dominik Raab der hat
nach Mobbing Vorwürfen seinen Rücktritt
erklärt unter anderem soll er
Mitarbeiter harsch zurechtgewiesen haben
Nachfolger wird der Chef des
kabinettbüros und frühere Vorsitzende
von sunex-
im Sudan ist die Lage weiter
unübersichtlich Deutschland und andere
Länder beraten evakuierungsoptionen für
ihre Staatsbürger nach erneut schweren
Gefechten zwischen der Armee und einer
paramilitärischen Gruppierung gab es am
abendmeldungen über einen neuen Anlauf
für eine Waffenruhe hunderte Menschen
sind seit Beginn der Kämpfe vor knapp
einer Woche ums Leben gekommen
Tage dienen immer auch der
Selbstvergewisserung wir sind wir bzw
was sind wir nicht da durfte in der
Parteitagsrede von FDP-Chef Linter
Lindner heute Linda nein Mensch
Entschuldigung Lindner sorry der
Seitenhieb auf die lastenradfahrer im
Prenzlauer Berg wohl nicht fehlen das
Radfahrer ist in dem Kiez eher schwer
haben sich durch zugeparkte Straßen zu
bewegen geschenkt die Botschaft war klar
die Liberalen sind nicht die Grünen sie
sind vor allem nicht links aber auch
nicht CDU die neuerdings darüber
nachdenkt Spitzenverdiener höher zu
besteuern um die Mittelschicht zu
entlasten
das eigene Profil zu schärfen ist für
die FDP-Führung umso wichtiger als die
letzten fünf Landtagswahlen für sie ja
ziemlich katastrophalen
es ist sein Applaus Christian Lindner
ist der alte und neue Chef der Freien
Demokraten er erhält 88 Prozent der
abgegebenen Stimmen auch wenn es vor
zwei Jahren noch 93% waren steht die FDP
demonstrativ zusammen und schärft das
eigene liberale Profil Stichwort
technologieoffenheit das Leben mit
Verbrennungsmotor im Thüringer Wald ist
nicht besser oder schlechter als das
Leben mit Lastenrad im Prenzlauer Berg
es sind schlichtfreie
Lebensentscheidungen die beiderseits
Respekt verdienen das Christian Lindner
von seiner Partei derart gefeiert wird
eigentlich überraschend lange Gesichter
bei allen Landtagswahlen seitdem die FDP
Teil der Ampelkoalition ist zweimal
fliegen die Liberalen aus der
Regierungsverantwortung dreimal
scheitern sie sogar an der 5% Hürde im
neuen ZDF Politbarometer steht die FDP
im Bund bei 6% wieso denn diese
Unterstützung für den Kurssetzer
Nachfrage bei den Delegierten denen
Wahlen in diesem Jahr noch bevorstehen
Christian Lindner ist nun mal unser
Gesicht für die Freien Demokraten er hat
die Partei mit aufgebaut wir kommen ja
schließlich aus der außerhalb
parlamentarischen Opposition vor einigen
Jahren der macht sich auch in der
Bundesregierung für die FDP-Position
stark das haben wir jetzt zuletzt im
Koalitionsausschuss gesehen die
Beschleunigung von autobahnprojekten und
die Aufweichung der Sektoren beim
Klimaschutzgesetz sind gemeint das gab
ordentlich Zoff mit den Grünen und
weiterer Zopf scheint schon programmiert
im Leitantrag des FDP Bundesvorstands
setzt die Partei trotz des Atomausstiegs
weiter auf die Kernenergie wir für
entsprechende Forschung und Entwicklung
Geld in die Hand nehmen und sie plant
die Zukunft für den Verbrenner if you
betrieben so dass bis spätestens 2045
nur noch CO2 neutrale Kraftstoffe
verkauft werden sollen die FDP will
keine Steuererhöhungen und alle aus
ihrer Sicht unnötigen Staatsausgaben
vermeiden bei Grünen und SPD könnte man
sich fragen was das etwa für die Kinder
Grund Absicherung bedeutet und bei der
FDP muss man fragen wie sollen all diese
Pläne mit den ampelpartnern zusammen
gehen wir wollen ein ganz klares Profil
setzen wir sagen auf diesen Parteitag
dass er ein Parteitag ist wofür unsere
Partei steht und unsere Minister müssen
dann schauen wie sie das oder was davon
sie umsetzen können in der
Bundesregierung es gibt sehr kontroverse
Diskussionen in unserer Gesellschaft und
das was die ampelregierung leisten muss
ist dass sie diese Kontroverse zu kommt
guten Kompromissen zusammenbringen so
sieht es auch die neue Vize-Chefin der
FDP Bildungsministerin Bettina stark
Watzinger gewählt mit 86% der Stimmen
die Partei steht demonstrativ zusammen
steckt sich und ihre Führungsriege nur
Nicola Bär die als Vize-Chefin den Platz
räumt gibt Christian Lindner noch einen
mit aber wohl ohne böse Absicht
und mit dem Blick auf die europäische
Wirtschaft geht es jetzt bei dir noch
mal weiter Heim da die Wirtschaft im
eurorama ist in dieses zweite Quartal
offenbar mit mehr Wachstum gestartet als
gedacht das geht aus dem heute
vorgelegten Einkaufsmanager Index hervor
bei der realer was genau lässt sich da
ablesen also der Einkaufsmanagerindex
der bekommt deswegen so viel Beachtung
weil er die Stimmung in Unternehmen
darstellt ein starker
Einkaufsmanagerindex ist also ein
Zeichen von Zuversicht und bedeutet das
Unternehmen bereit sind Geld in die Hand
zu nehmen nun ist der Index in der
Eurozone im April so stark wie knapp ein
Jahr nicht mehr das gilt nicht für alle
Bereiche Dienstleistungen boomen die
Industrie tut sich schwerer auch gibt es
regionale Unterschiede Deutschland ist
stark Frankreich weniger weil dort
Unternehmen unter den Protesten gegen
die Rentenreform leiden alles in allem
aber wieder mehr Zuversicht auch bei
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck er will seine
Wachstumsprognose für dieses Jahr
verdoppeln konkrete Zahlen am Mittwoch
und was machen in diesem Umfeld die
Aktienkurse die Stimmung an den
Aktienmärkten ist auch weitgehend
zuversichtlich seit Jahresanfang hat der
DAX schon über 14 Prozent zugelegt auch
heute wieder ein kleines Plus und damit
nur knapp unter 16.000 auf den
Aktienmärkten bald die Puste ausgeht
wird unter anderem von den kommenden
Konjunkturindikatoren abhängen und davon
gibt es allein nächste Woche eine ganze
Reihe
vielen Dank
für Muslime rund um den Globus hat mit
dem Ende des Ramadan das Fastenbrechen
begonnen drei Tage lang wird gefeiert
nach gemeinsamen Gebeten am Morgen wie
hier im für Muslime heiligen Mekka
kommen meist Familien und Freunde
zusammen und teilen eine üppige Mahlzeit
wie hier in dem Palästinenser Gebieten
aber auch Kinder stehen im Mittelpunkt
werden mit Süßigkeiten bedacht und wie
diese afghanischen Mädchen und Jungen
mit besonderen Spielgelegenheiten
[Musik]
weltweit sind die Gletscher im
vergangenen Jahr mit einer dramatischen
Geschwindigkeit geschmolzen zu diesem
Ergebnis kommt die Weltorganisation für
Meteorologie in ihrem heute
veröffentlichten Klima Jahresbericht und
die Meeresspiegel steigen demnach immer
rascher an und sie erreichten im
vergangenen Jahr einen Rekordstand die
vergangenen acht Jahre sein die wärmsten
Jahre seit Beginn der
Wetteraufzeichnungen gewesen
sie gelten als eine der wichtigsten
Auszeichnungen für Fernsehproduktionen
in Deutschland in Marl sind heute die
gremme Preise verliehen worden insgesamt
wurden 19 Auszeichnungen verliehen im
Bereich Fiktion mehrmals ausgezeichnet
wurde das ZDF unter anderem für den Film
die Wannseekonferenz und die Drama Serie
Neuland im Bereich Unterhaltung nahm jan
Böhmermann einen Grimme Preis für die
satirische ZDF-Magazin Royale entgegen
zum nun schon 6 mal
und hier geht's jetzt weiter mit dem
neuen ZDF Politbarometer dafür hat die
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen unter anderem
Fragen zum Klimaschutz und zum
Atomausstieg gestellt und natürlich die
Sonntagsfrage die Ergebnisse präsentiert
Ihnen jetzt Matthias
herzlich willkommen zum Politbarometer
der Klimawandel hat an Fahrt aufgenommen
viele Menschen sind deshalb besorgt
jeder zweite sieht im Thema Klima und
Energie das wichtigste Problem in
Deutschland über den richtigen Umgang
damit wird gestritten Klimaschutz
polarisiert die Gesellschaft wird genug
getan wie hoch sind die Belastungen und
welche Art Protest ist akzeptabel
ein Viertel der Befragten sagt es wird
zu viel für den Klimaschutz getan fast
genauso viele finden die Maßnahmen
gerade richtig eine Mehrheit von 48
Prozent meint bislang passiert zu wenig
das zu viel getan wird für den
Klimaschutz finden mehrheitlich die
Anhänger der AFD bei den unionsanhängern
sieht das fast jeder dritte so
und fast jeder zweite sieht für sich
starke oder sehr starke finanzielle
Belastungen durch Umweltschutzmaßnahmen
klimaaktivisten wollen dagegen mehr
Tempo bei der Rettung des Klimas
erzwingen mit
illegalen Aktionen wie Straßenblockaden
stoßen sie allerdings bei einer sehr
großen Mehrheit der Deutschen auf
Ablehnung
schauen wir auf ein anderes streithema
Lohnerhöhungen dafür kämpfen im Moment
zahlreiche Berufsgruppen Wochenende
gehen die Tarifverhandlungen im
öffentlichen Dienst weiter
64 Prozent der Deutschen meinen die
Gewerkschaften sollten dem aktuellen
Schlichtungsvorschlag zustimmen danach
würden die Beschäftigten unter anderem
eine Sonderzahlung von 3000 Euro
erhalten und im kommenden Jahr 5,5%
Millionen und Gehalt 27 Prozent der
Befragten sind gegen den Vorschlag und
wollen dass die Gewerkschaften bei ihren
höheren Forderungen bleiben
schauen wir aufs Kräfteverhältnis der
Parteien in Deutschland da gibt es
einige Bewegungen wenn am nächsten
Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre käme die SPD
auf 18 Prozent minus 1 die cdu/csu 31
Prozent plus 1 grüne 18 Prozent plus 1
fdp6-1 AFD 15 unverändert die Linke vier
Prozent minus 1 und die anderen Parteien
zusammen 8% + 1
und wie werden die wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker bewertet da
kann vor allem Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius Punkten Bundeskanzler Scholz
und Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck müssen
dagegen persönliche Negativrekorde
einstecken unsere Top Ten nach Sympathie
und Leistung auf der Skala von +5 bis -5
Schlusslicht ist weiter Sarah
Wagenknecht minus 1,5 davor nennt sie
Fräser minus 0,5 beide etwas schlechter
Markus Söder -0,3 unverändert auf Fragen
7 Christian Lindner minus 0,3 schlechter
Karl Lauterbach -0,3 etwas besser vor
ihm Friedrich Merz -0,3 etwas schlechter
Robert Habeck 0,0 Olaf Scholz 0,2 beide
verschlechtert und auf persönlichem
Rekordtief davor Annalena baerbock 0,2
unverändert
weiter an der Spitze Boris Pistorius 1,8
deutlich besser
von Bundeskanzler Scholz wird bei
Konflikten innerhalb der Ampelkoalition
auch eine Vermittlerrolle erwartet
Entscheidungen dauern dann auch mal
länger manche legen stolz das als
Führungsschwäche aus
32% der deutschen meinen Scholz setzt
sich hin wichtigen politischen Fragen
eher durch 61 Prozent bezweifeln das bei
Entscheidungen ist der Bundeskanzler
eher zu zögerlich meinen fast
dreiviertel der Befragten 22% finden das
nicht
FDP-Chef Christian Lindner zeigt sich in
der Koalition oft streitbar für die
Partei seit fast zehn Jahren und will
das auch weiter tun beim Parteitag in
Berlin geht es um den künftigen Kurs der
Liberalen
40 Prozent der Befragten glauben dass
Lindner die FDP erfolgreich in die
Zukunft führen wird
49% glauben das nicht bei den
FDP-Anhängern hat er mit 82% deutlichem
Rückhalt nur 10% trauen ihm den Erfolg
nicht zu
der Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine geht unvermindert weiter
westliche Staaten haben weitere
Militärhilfen für die Ukraine zugesagt
das trifft auf breite Zustimmung 28
Prozent der Befragten meinen die
militärische Unterstützung sollte noch
stärker ausfallen 45 Prozent wollen eine
Fortsetzung wie bisher 22 Prozent
sprechen sich für weniger Militärhilfen
aus darunter besonders viele in
Ostdeutschland
stärkere militärische Unterstützung
wünschen sich vor allem die Anhänger von
Grünen und SPD an baldige
Friedensverhandlungen glaubt kaum jemand
nur rund jeder zehnte
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite 165
in der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
zustande kommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den Qualitätsstandards
finden Sie unter
politbarometer.zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es dann am 5
Mai dann blicken wir mit einem
Politbarometer extra auch auf die
Bürgerschaftswahl in Bremen
nach dem Wetter geht es hier weiter mit
der heute-
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend zum Wetter ein
warmes Wochenende dann wieder eine
kühlere nächste Woche das ganze kommt
Folgen der Master Zustande wir haben im
Moment tiefen Druck über Westeuropa also
sozusagen ein azorentief kein Azoren
hoch und ein Ableger ein Ableger dieses
Tiefdruckgebiets bringt uns zunächst
einmal am Wochenende mildere Luft dann
zieht es aber so über uns hinweg dass
wir auf die kühle Seite dieses Tiefs
gelangen und mit in Kombination mit
diesem Hoch gelangt dann aus Nordwesten
Polarluft zu uns und das zeigt uns auch
der temperaturtrend von Berlin der am
Wochenende knapp 20 Grad zeigt aber bis
Mitte nächste Woche auf unter 10 Grad
singt jetzt ist es aber erstmal mild
heute Nacht vor allem im Westen des
Landes im Süden und im Osten ist es mit
drei bis sieben Grad kühler hier ist es
auch sternenklar Schauer und Gewitter im
Süden lassen rasch nach da gibt's dann
etwas Nebel aber die kräftigen Gewitter
von heute Abend die sind im Westen noch
länger unterwegs wenn dann auch die
nachgelassen haben dann kann der Tag
morgen mit viel Sonne starten und
Vorsicht die hat schon wirklich Kraft im
Verlauf des Tages kommen dann aus Westen
Südwesten showerartige Regenfälle Lokal
wieder mit Gewittern und einem
auffrischenden südlichen Wind nur ganz
im Osten bleibt es sonnig mit dieser
sonnenunterstützung schaffen wir es im
norddeutschen Tiefland auf über 20 Grad
in der Eifel zum Beispiel oder den
Regenwolken sind es nur 14 Grad und der
Trend ab Sonntag der ist klar Regen
immer wieder auch mal Gewitter und mit
den Temperaturen geht's bergab auf nur
noch fünf bis zehn Grad am Dienstag
April macht einfach was er will tschüss